you
hi I'm Garrick Ruhlman a professional
educator our studio and the author of
two books on our I've put together these
videos to teach you some of the main
ideas of doing data wrangling with our
and the tidy verse if you're not
familiar with the tidy verse it's a
collection of our packages that are
designed to help you do data science in
this series of short videos we will walk
through some of the most useful tools
for wrangling your data with our before
we dive in I want to briefly motivate
why this topic is so important and
outline how these resources are
organized to quote an article from the
New York Times data scientists spend
from 50% to 80% of their time mired in
the mundane labor of collecting and
preparing data before it can be explored
for useful information I'm not sure if
this labor really is mundane but the
simple fact is that before and our
program can look for answers your data
must be cleaned up and converted to a
form that makes information accessible
learning to do this well is the best
investment that you can make in yourself
as a data scientist in these videos you
will learn how to use the deep liar and
tidier packages to optimize the data
wrangling process you'll learn to spot
the variables and observations within
your data to quickly drive new variables
and observations to explore to reshape
your data into the layout that works
best for our to join multiple datasets
together and to use group wise summaries
to explore hidden levels of information
within your data also keep in mind that
you can skip around these videos to the
tool that you want by clicking the jump
to links in the video description
this webinar will we'll go through two
packages that have the Wickham my
colleague made and they're both really
geared towards working with the
structure of data so that's the tidy our
package and the deep liar package and
then what I'm going to do
really follows closely a cheat sheet
that we published a couple days ago so
this is a cheat sheet you could download
at the link at the bottom of the slide
here and it's a two-page sheet that just
summarizes the tidier package in the
deep-fryer package so it's a great
resource for remembering the functions
that we go through today and also for
this remembering functions in general as
you work with data
so before we really get in a date or
ankling there's a couple of ground rules
that I want to familiarize you with so
these two packages introduce some things
into our that makes our work better but
it also makes our look a little
different so I just wanna make sure
you're comfortable with that before we
start using them and the first is the
table structure or table TBL and what is
what a table is I'm gonna say table
looks like don't like Ted well but it's
just a dataframe basically you can think
of as a data frame that appears two
differently in your console window so
for example if I go over here to my our
window this is just our studio window
that I cut off on the side here alright
and I open up a familiar library like
ggplot2 you there is a data set in here
called diamonds which is humongous and
if you try to look at this data frame
well this is what happened it it fills
up my screen and at some point R tells
me that it's not going to show the rest
of the data this data set is 52,000 rows
and really what I do see here isn't very
helpful a fills up my memory buffer
which means I can't see what I did
before and B I can't even see the names
of this data frame so what a table is is
a new class that you could give to a
data structure like diamonds and it's
implement
the deep liar package here so I can
change diamonds into a table with this
function table underscore D F and now I
have the same data frame here but the
print method is only going to show me
the part of the data frame that fits in
my console window so it showed me right
now that there's a variable called Y and
a variable called Z in the diamond
stated frame that went off the side of
the window instead of wrapping them
below our now is just go tell me these
variables are here but they're not shown
and then instead of showing me 52,000
rows it's just going to show me 10 rows
so this is a more pretty way to look at
your data if I were to change my console
window to something wider and then I
looked at my table diamonds I get those
extra variables here
it pays attention to how wide my window
is so it knows how many variables that
can show I call this again not only
shows up to depth and so on so this is a
very useful way to look at large data
sets or work with large data sets but
you at times will still want to see your
complete data so there's a function I
recommend to use when you want to look
at the entire dataset and that's the
view function it's in base R and if you
call it from our studio our su will open
up a spreadsheet like view window where
you could check out your dataset almost
as if it were an Excel document keep in
mind that's view with the capital V and
you could use this on any data frame
that you have an R now there's one last
function that really changes how our
looks and that's the pipe operator this
comes from the Magruder package but it's
imported by the deep liar package and
it's a different way to write the same
code that you'd write before so you can
probably recognize what this command
would do here we haven't looked at
select we'll look at that today but it's
calling select on an object called TB
and then it has some arguments here the
pipe operator allows you to pipe in the
first argument of select so I'd write TB
pipe select child to elderly now what
the operator will do is they'll insert
TBS of
argument of select so these two lines of
code would do the same thing if we come
over here we could you know ain't take a
look that so if I had diamonds I could
pipe in and I just take one variable
from diamonds maybe at the X column and
I could pipe that into the mean and if I
run this code it's going to give me the
mean of the X column which is the same
as if I did mean diamonds X so at this
point it might not be obvious why you'd
use pipe over anything else but the cool
thing about this format is you can start
chaining arguments together so if I
wander around every value in the X
column of diamonds to the second decimal
place and then take the mean I can use
this code here which won't look all that
different instead of actually saying
like okay let's around all the stuff and
save that and then call mean on the
output as your chains get longer and
longer this becomes much more efficient
than actually managing where you save
they in between states so let's take a
look at the
I can actually help you wrangle data and
what I mean by data wrangling is what
other people call munging or transform
your data or manipulating it and the
reason I use the word wrangling is it
sort of captures how painful this
process can be that's just getting the
format of your data into a format that
you can work with is time-consuming and
it's often boring and painful and if you
could do that more efficiently that
would be a big win and the functions
we'll look at today will help you do
that thanks for checking out our data
wrangling video series this is just one
video in a larger set of resources on
data wrangling so here are links to all
of our other videos in the series and
again have a look at the video
description for shortcuts to other parts
of the series as well as other resources
we think might be helpful like cheat
sheets and further documentation we hope
you find all of these resources useful
and if you do as always we would
appreciate a thumbs up or a share both
go a long way to helping this content
reach people who could benefit from it